mo i just want to say i was a huge fan
of pitch so i was excited to see this as
your directorial debut um just to get
started can you talk a little bit about
this project and just give audiences an
idea of what the film is about the movie
is called a lot of nothing and it's
essentially about this
uh beautiful well-to-do married couple
who on the surface seem like everything
is great and wonderful and deep beneath
that they actually have a lot of issues
they're trying to sort out watching the
news one night and discover that their
next-door neighbor
committed what they believed to be a
crime and decide to take matters into
their own hand and approach that
neighbor and then quickly discover that
they are ill-equipped to deal with the
fallout around approaching him and
everything that ensues after that and
where did you get the idea for this film
when you were you know when you were
thinking up something for your
directorial debut it was like a few
different things it was a combination of
like always
having
really deep conversations with my
friends be like david and close friends
of ours about things that are happening
in the world and all the emotions around
it so i wanted to try to create a story
that allowed me to
examine what do we do
with all the pressure from everything
that we're feeling on a macro level and
what happens when that collides with all
like very interpersonal relationships on
a micro level and i want to do it in an
entertaining way so this felt like the
perfect way to do it
i mean
i would like to speak just now to david
as a producer how did you get involved
in this project was it just through
being friends with mo or was did you
hear hear about it um through somebody
else
well i mean mo is is one of my best
friends in the world one of my favorite
people on the planet and um we met uh
doing a film called the butler together
and
very soon after
being around him i was very aware that i
was
witnessing a great talent a great mind
someone who
is a true artist and so
i've been
not just his friend but a fan uh ever
since then i just found out that ten
years ago is when we actually made the
butler which is so crazy
um
so um so yeah so when mo presented me
with this
script
it didn't surprise me as to how well
realized it was you know people may not
know but mo is also a brilliant
photographer
and so between seeing the images he had
already been creating as a photographer
the voice i was now realizing he had as
a writer
and the acting ability that i had seen
and had a front row seat to both on set
and watching his other work i had no
doubt that he was going to be able to
create something
um compelling
but you know the the end product i i
have to admit even exceeds my
expectations it's just so
so well realized a very unusually
accomplished uh directorial debut and um
yeah i couldn't be more proud of him i'm
sort of both a friend and a fan i'm very
curious mo i know you co-wrote the
script with uh sarah kelly kaplan
i want to know um about the writing
process and how that went and how the
partnership went with you and sarah oh
well that was i mean first of all david
is like before i talk about the sarah
thing david that means so much hearing
those words from you because i never
forget that i don't want to go too far
into off topic but i remember the first
time i met david on the butler and i had
been a fan of his work
and had no idea he would have known who
i was in that moment i was like came
later into the production it was lunch
and i'm sitting there like the new kid
in class by myself and he walks over to
me i just saw you in this thing you were
lovely in it and it was like this
gun and he was friends with the director
so she has he got a a sneak peek and
from that point of like developing that
friendship and then being like brothers
and deeply deeply entrenched in this
idea of like
creating great art
and celebrating authenticity and pushing
each other to do the best we can so i'm
so happy that we're having this
opportunity together on this project
because it's really been a
long time coming and like a deep
yearning to put things into the world
that we could feel proud of that could
make people think and feel
when
so i'm just very appreciative of this
time in this moment and sarah
came through the writing process pretty
late into it actually because this whole
thing started like in 2018 as a short
film so i first made it as a short film
with makai pfeiffer and paris henley in
it and paul hunter and pretty bird
helped me produce it and annie clemens
who was a producer on the feature as
well so it started there when i first
had the idea then i spent a significant
amount of time writing it and developing
into a feature
and i was
acting
and
we were getting close to finishing it
and we had a lot of great notes coming
in from like david and anonymous and i
just couldn't really implement those
notes and i knew i needed a fresh fresh
set of eyes and a new take insert the
genius sarah kelly kaplan who like me is
from la who like me is a really uh she's
really fascinated with social
interactions and things of that nature
very talented artist so she was able to
come in towards the end and i think it
really add
all the uh extra levels of nuance and
things that were needed especially also
being a woman and being able to bring
this specificity to the female
characters in the film that's great i
mean i didn't know about the short i
love parisa by the way so i'm i'm happy
i need to like find that somewhere so i
can watch it
um david as an actor and also as a
producer um what is it about producing
that draws you to
that role
um well for me it's born out of
necessity you know the the reality is
when mo talks about our conversations
around the kind of things we want to see
in the world
a lot of the time
those conversations are driven by the
fact that there is a death
of that material a dearth of that
representation of who we are the
complexities of who we are
um and you know we can either sit around
waiting for someone else to come up with
those narratives that we can then be a
part of or we can come up with them
ourselves and so it's been born out of
necessity but it's become a passion
because you know i've been a beneficiary
of people advocating for me pretty
seriously um you know giving me roles
that took me to places i didn't know i
could go before and i've now
increasingly seen the power of being
able to advocate for others you know any
kind of notoriety that i have gained
can be used to open doors for others and
selfishly continually open doors for me
because if you um
create an environment where a moma cray
is normalized then the the the material
the platform the attention the audience
is going to grow you know you can build
an ecosystem um and so you know
producing is exactly that you are making
things and you are making things happen
and so that's why i'm so passionate
about it because you know i just refuse
to be someone who's going to wait for
someone else to give me or the people
who i really believe in opportunities
that that that responsibility should and
and does fall to me
well i love that i mean without that i
don't think we would get to see
this finished product so i'm i'm glad
that i'm glad that you picked up on it
um so just shifting to the actual film
this is going to be a question for both
of you was there a specific moment in
this film or maybe like a scene or a
character that really really responded
to you when you saw the final product
and mo i'll start with you that's a
tough question for me because i'm so
like
i didn't get the
and i hope this doesn't come across the
wrong way but almost like the luxury
of seeing the finished product
being able to step away from it and come
back because i you know it was almost
like watching
uh
not paint dry because that sounds
terribly boring but when you see your
kids grow every day when you're there
every day sometimes you don't react to
them in the same way as the person that
hasn't seen your kid in a year
and they come and see the kids like oh
my god what they get so like i see
david's kids and they have mustaches now
i'm like an annoying uncle i'm like look
at you that's your mustache come here he
got a beard and they're just like no
please stop just
use them every day but what i will say
for me the the moment
where
it kind of all came together i guess
would be the first time
when i got to experience it once the
sound design had been completed the
color and the film was
finally married
and then i got to see just like i get
emotional just thinking about just
seeing
everyone's hard work come together
all as one so i don't know if it's one
particular thing outside of the just the
collaboration
and once i got to experience it all
complete it was a moment that i just it
just struck me like wow we have
something that i'm incredibly proud of
and affected by as like an audience i
was able to watch it for the first time
as an audience member and was just
really um
yeah i just love the whole thing what it
ended up being to be honest there's no
one single thing it's the entire process
and coming together and being realized
and david what about you
um i think for me it was the short film
it was the original short film it was
incredibly ambitious i can't remember mo
exactly how many minutes long but it was
like something like 15 minutes long
or thereabouts and the entire film was
in one take
um and
that in and of itself to just make that
actually work which it did
was astounding but then the tone
it had this tone that didn't shy away
from the social commentary but had this
sort of absurdist
humor um it was sort of
dark but light
um
it showed black affluence while talking
about
issues around the criminalization of of
of black people and it then also spoke
to apathy from black people in relation
to
um the marginalization the
criminalization so
all of that was in this 15 minute one
shot short
and i just thought
that's that's a lot to to do and do well
in a short
and
mo
managed to do that and more with the
with the feature length script and i
knew from watching the show that he has
the vision for it he has the the visual
eye for it um and that the tone is
something quite unique and i think that
you know modern day audiences are
rightfully demanding they don't want you
to just bring them a thriller or just
bring them a horror or just bring them a
drama you've got to be you know
punching above that way in order to
really corral their interest
and and this was doing it in the short
it was doing in the script i had no
doubt it would do it in the eventual um
film but what i now feel when i watch
the film is how visually stunning it is
the performances by cleopatra and yolan
and justin and shamir and lex as well
that they are
it is
so well paced in my opinion uh you know
hopefully people agree
but also for for the film to feel
tonally even considering just how many
things are going on
is is sort of in my opinion a kind of a
miraculous feat which i'm so proud of mo
for for pulling off so you know it was
all there in the original short film and
has only been elevated as it's gotten
all the way to the feature well that
sounds i mean i i have to agree that i
felt that same way from just the opening
scene of the film right before the
credits i felt like that stretch was
just like you know the a moose bouche if
you will of the film to get like sort of
the the the vibe which is like
both like speaking on social commentary
but also like you said like that
absurdist sort of comedic tone which is
like had me like chuckling at times and
also like oh my god this could go off
the rails very quickly
so i'd love to talk to you about that
first opening scene mo and um filming
that did that come from the short film
did that come from you know just just
you know amazing idea that you had
the opening
so i must give credit to
uh paul hunter who was a is a phenomenal
director friend of david dinars and
he gave me the idea when i first came to
him with the short that i should do it
in one shot
it was his idea to do it in one shot
and
i
immediately it's one of those things
where you someone says something to you
and it's like yes
that's it because that gave me the
opportunity to give the audience a
glimpse into the dynamics of these
characters in real time
no cuts i'm a fly on the wall i'm a
guest that they don't know i'm a voyeur
and i watch it play out and the idea of
that stuck with me and i knew
in order for me to walk the tight rope
of the tone of this film that that
opening would serve as a prologue and
introduce the audience to everything
that essentially would have unfolded in
the film thematically in that one shot
and it was one of those things where
the two things about me i am
super receptive and open of criticism
thoughts and feedback but i am also
incredibly stubborn and diligent about
my own instincts and so when everybody
try to tell me mo you can't start your
movie with a 17-minute warner
you can't do that that was the one thing
it was a non-negotiable for me i knew
this film
had to start that way and it was just it
was incredibly difficult and everyone
rose to the occasion like we we all
cried
on set
because it was such a difficult thing to
accomplish and when we knew we did it
and it was like that magic almost like
in the theater like a lie like a play we
go to the cinema i mean to see a
live show and that magic and that moment
before is what everyone felt like the
lights twinkled different that night in
the house it felt like and everybody
just really was so dialed in and that's
just how it had to be
and that's what we're able to do
i mean i'm glad you stuck to your guns
on that one because i think that is like
one of the best uh scenes of the entire
film is that that first scene it really
really sets the tone for the film in my
opinion and it you know it
it it sets that sets up the two
characters really really well and that's
something that i really want to talk to
you about is the casting um i love you
on i love cleopatra i thought cleopatra
was magnificent in this um i would just
like to know when it came to casting
when it came to finding these two
characters uh what was the process like
arduous
it was an arduous uh well thought
process i had leslie wu
who was a phenomenal casting director
she was just coming off of the farewell
and she had so much passion for the
project
i met with a lot of casting directors
but she
i'll never forget her emailing my
manager and saying
this movie is special it is important it
has to be done it has to be done at the
highest level even if mo decides not to
select me to be his casting director i
would still love to give him ideas
and thoughts to help be sure he has the
best cast possible
and
it's my first time writing a script my
first feature that i put into the world
and i have someone that was having such
a beautiful moment in her career
expand that type of energy i was like
you know this has to be the person and
everything that i was able to glean from
that email
she executed so
casting was her any clemens of myself
and we
read everybody we met everybody and i
always kind of had a line in my mind
because we did a film together and i
think he's a tremendous actor
you see he's super good looking
charismatic but he does not rely on that
he is a trained actor he is a thespian
he is willing to go to the depths of his
soul to bring every ounce of everything
that was necessary and when he came in
through the audition process it was like
that's my guy
that's my guy and cleopatra
cleo
i did not know her
beforehand i had met her once at a party
i was with my wife and i remember
meeting my wife and i meeting her and
thinking like wow she's really beautiful
and lovely has a great energy about her
her and her manager but i wasn't very
familiar with the work and she came in
and
i i i just felt like oh my god
this is special she has something i had
never seen she reminds me very much of a
a combination
and then i say this i'm just going to be
a very big combination but i want to
stick to this
like um
meryl streep
angelina jolie
and some like angela bassett and it was
just like this thing she had power she
had appealed it was nuanced electricity
and in a chemistry red and i was just
like i can't wait to start photographing
these people on set
yeah it definitely had that energy i
think you're right about that
combination though for her
yes it's unlike anything i've ever seen
it was just like this combination of
things i had never seen
she embodied all the elements on a human
level that i was looking for this
character because it was inspired by a
real person from my life who was
biracial and was dealing with identity
things and how that kind of influenced
and and guided some of the choices she
would make as she was trying to sort
that out and that was something that
cleo had actually experienced throughout
the course of her life as well that she
was able to infuse into the characters
so it really felt like a perfect
marriage
amazing well i have so many more
questions and so many more thoughts
about this film
but um i just want to wrap it up with
the fact that i love the conversations
that this film is going to start i think
um it's it tacos so many different
things and obviously race is one of the
big things but i think class is also
such a large topic that it looks at and
i really really enjoy the sort of
nuanced conversations that we see
between the characters you know and it's
it's such a privilege to get to speak to
you too and i really want to thank you
for your time and uh yeah thanks
you